plans by the bosnian serb leadership to
exit some of the country's tripartite
institutions including the military are
described by the international
community's high representative
christian schmidt as tantamount to
succession they constitute he says the
greatest existential threat of the
post-war period
he's talking about bosnian serb leader
milorad doddik who says a new army will
be set up in the serb run entity of
republika serpska with the bosnian army
forced to withdraw if necessary he says
the serbs will call on their friends for
help a presumed reference to serbia
proper and russia a republican
the republic of sebsco will control its
own affairs in a legal constitutional
manner including by having its own army
judiciary fiscal administration as well
as intelligence and security agencies we
will re-establish all these institutions
last month a training exercise by
bosnian serb police was denounced by
muslim bosniak and croat leaders the
other members of a three-way power
sharing government formed by the 1995
dayton peace agreement
they took place on the mountain
overlooking sarajevo from where serbs
snipers and artillery laid siege to the
capital beginning in 1992. thousands of
civilians died in a war that culminated
in what international judges have called
genocide when more than 8 000 muslim men
and boys were massacred by serb troops
in the eastern enclave of srebrenica
the high representatives report to the
un this week says there is a very real
prospect of a return to conflict in
bosnia but there is no obvious appetite
on the part of western powers to
increase their security presence there
political tensions are part of daily
life in a country such as boston
herzegovina where you have different
groups competing for political power
but you did never see threats
uh off be it violence or be it secession
or be it parallel institutions come this
far as they have now at least not in a
very long time
milorad doddik has for years called for
the separation of the serb run part of
bosnia from the rest of the country
just weeks ago dodeck shared these
scenes on social media he and colleagues
singing serb nationalist folk songs in
their sarajevo headquarters it was a
reminder that the u.s sponsored peace in
bosnia did not bring ethnic harmony nor
did it come with any long-term guarantee
jonah al jazeera